Democrats say president Trump is
assembling a war cabinet and they say
CIA director Mike Pompeo as Secretary of
State would be part of that Pompeyo
testifying at his confirmation hearing
before the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee says as an Army veteran he
advocates war only as a last option
there are a few people like soldiers who
appreciate diplomats and good diplomatic
work you train you prepare you want very
you want very much to be prepared if
America calls upon you but you are
counting on the fact that there will be
diplomats around the world resolving
these challenges Democrats first
question for the Secretary of State
designate
Special Counsel Robert Muller's
investigation into election interference
and president Trump's attacks on it
Pompeyo confirmed the special counsel's
office interviewed him and then refused
to say whether the president asked him
to intervene on that investigation
during a meeting at the White House last
year what was the subject of the
conversation senator I'm not gonna speak
to that I'm going to not speak about any
of the three investigations that I have
been a participant in today he stressed
the president never asked him to do
anything improper and that if President
Trump fired the special counsel he
likely would not resign in protest if
confirmed quickly Pompeo would handle
negotiations with Europeans on Iran
policy
he says there's still a chance the US
could stay in the Iran nuclear deal if
European governments agree to a stronger
posture towards Iran Democrats and some
Republicans warned against withdrawing
from the nuclear deal because Iran has
already received the benefits Pompeyo
argues ending the agreement can still
halts benefits to Iran they're still
receiving enormous economic benefits
even as we sit here this morning
Pompeyo says if the u.s. withdraws he'll
push for a tougher agreement on Russia
he says he'll advocate the u.s. push
back against Russian aggression I take a
backseat to no one with my views of the
threat that is presented to America from
Russia as CIA director Pompeo has been
deeply involved in preparations for the
potential summit between Kim jong-un and
President Trump
Pompeyo would not rule out a military
action against North Korea though he
says there's a long diplomatic road
before then today that's the number-one
priority for this administration
ADEs close to the process acknowledged a
final confirmation vote for Pompeo may
not happen until next month the chairman
of this committee bob Corker says he
expects Pompeo to receive bipartisan
support and he'll likely need it
Republican Senator Rand Paul says he
already opposes Pompeo and Republicans
only have a thin majority in the Senate
Chris more on this with the panel rich
thank you